the reigning MVP says high level those
numbers on your screen that's Allstar
level career high in points career high
and assist and on this show we always
say we're taking it to the max whenever
we talk to Tyree Maxi let's welcome in
the fouryear 23y old what's up my friend
what it do how does it feel that when
people introduce you now they say
Allstar caliber player when you do get
that nomination and are called an allar
star what would that mean to you uh you
know honestly for me it would mean that
we're doing something right as a team
you know it means we're winning means
that we have a chance to do something
special and I feel like you don't get
those accolades or you know those
recognitions unless you're winning so
think we're doing something good right
now on this show you get the assist to
cand this next great great great I get
the pass to you you already have a ball
I mean I'll just go like that okay there
there we go there we go um you know
obviously coming into this year uh Your
Role got bigger and with that your
leader leadership got bigger how is it
to to to come out and perform the way
that you have performed but then also
have the confidence of a Joel embiid
that has been MVP has played with
amazing guards but to have that
confidence from him that's got to feel
amazing it feels great I'm not going to
lie it started early early in my career
you know people don't know this but like
I tell everybody he's like one of the um
first Believers in me honestly I think
uh I tell his story frequently now it
was a game where he sat out we had the
co situation going on and he asked me
like can you get 40 tonight and I'm like
it's like my 10th game in the NBA I'm
like 40 points that sound like so many
like I barely got that in high school
but I went out there I ended up with
like 39 I'm like well if Joelle believe
in me I think you know I think I can do
something right but uh I just really
appreciate him he pushes me he pushes me
and I think that uh now that I've kind
of gained his respect I'm allowed to
kind of push him as well so it's been
great I appreciate them everybody talks
about your work ethic and they all talk
about how great of a teammate you are
and your attitude can you speak to the
young kids kids out there how important
that part of the game is like being a
good teammate how have you always been
like that yeah I think it's extremely
important uh my dad was a coach growing
up you know he played division one
basketball so I had to be extremely
coachable and he was always on me so I
you know I felt like I was that you know
the coach on the court for him and for
me I just always want to uplift my guys
uplift my teammates uh whether that's
just positive attitude whether that's
just going at them in practice whether
that's us competing in practice or us
hanging out off the court I feel like
you can't go to war and can't go to
battle with somebody if you don't really
know them and I try to get to know
everybody on my team everybody in the
organization so I really know them that
we can go out there that way we can go
out there and be successful on the court
all right listen so we know it's a make
or Miss league right shoot the three
shoot the three well with the best of
them but you also finish down here with
the best of them uh we work out with a
trainer Chris Johnson got to give uh
Chris Johnson some love and you know I
want to talk about the levels of
finishing because you've taken your
finishing to another level this season
last year you were at at 58% this year
you're finishing amongst the best at 64%
around this here Rim right seven Footers
in there trying to block your shot so
I'm I'mma throw in a little assist okay
and let's talk about a little bit of the
level so we c c you know CJ talks about
the level one right level two is right
where the square is level three is high
up now we know you know Jamal kind of
perfected that he was go he's doing it
different he's doing it different so
what can you say about your finishing
and how you continue to improve that
right first of all like you said shout
out to Chris uh he's somebody who taught
me like the levels of the backboard but
as a kid I will give a shout out to
Kyrie because Kyrie does a drill where
he stand the goal and he's using his
wrist work you know what I mean and just
finding a touch on the glass so now for
me I just know like if I get any type of
contact I know the levels of the you
know the rim that I can put the ball to
and spin it to where I can have it give
it a chance to go in so honestly man
it's just a lot of work a lot a lot of
work I do a lot of finishes off the
right right left left just because I'm
smaller um I knew I was going to be
small at a young age you know my dad's
small my mom's small uh and just you
know God blessed me with this height so
I mean this is great but I I just knew I
going to use floaters use Touch shots
use different bank uh Bank shots and it
works for me can we see one or two I see
you keep looking at the back boy I'm
trying to see what you're looking at see
or two I was just trying to see the
angle okay okay okay you ain't got to
show us too much I saw that one but no
that level right there that third one no
it's oh you got that to you got yeah
it's little spin that's the finisher
right there that's the finisher right
there no so we see it here but how about
some of the moves we've seen you do in
games we got Jamal who is a master of
the best moves on the floor last week we
were watching your game and it was like
oh the move against the Bulls you go
Baseline crossover and reverse Jamal
tell us what you think of some of these
moves yeah the killer crossover he hit
the step back on Dame everybody knows
Dame likes the step back right here the
change of pace he put him in jail right
there got the floater and then it's the
way he's dancing The Defenders reacting
to him that's the one right there that's
the one
so so so like a move like that one can
we demonstrate that I'll be the defender
cuz I a't play no defense they going to
help tell us tell us what tell
us tell us what you're looking at well
I'll say I'll say this first and
foremost I'm trying to get low I play
with the MVP he has a lot of gravity
right so they don't want me coming off
his screen because if I get to come off
pocket passes all those type of things
so they're trying extremely hard to get
over so for me I could use speed so what
I'm saying just one little jab I'm
jumping you're gone I'm crossing now we
get down here like we talked about
finish and stuff honestly I just I just
use my instincts you know what I mean
the guy comes over I'm already trying to
see Demar coming low man I know dear is
very athletic I'm trying to go around
him I don't want to go through him he's
going vertical they're not going to call
foul I'm going all the way around to the
other side using my love was in my touch
I love it big game moments show me show
me your go-to move let's go what's your
area where you like to be tell show me
what's going on well for me if I get a
ISO situation I like to find my way into
this slot this this slot why this slot
because I can I got to tell you all my
street my
my listen but serious though I like cuz
for me I talked to James Harden a lot
when he was on our team right and he had
a lot of different go-to moves and a lot
of his setup start with between legs so
for me because I can go between and I
can use my quickness that little
hesitation helps me a lot to get
downhill so now if I have a big on me
and they're sagging off I can use that
for the hey stack come back and I get
back to my little pullback My Little
James Harden step back shout out to J
cuz he perfected that and I kind of
stole that from him so let me ask you
this because I mean we all are very
prideful of our you know universities
Jamal was celebrating yesterday because
of Michigan I was like all right
Tennessee you know what I'm saying you
got Tobi Tobias Harris on your team we
rock you know Rocky Top y'all yall close
but but Kentucky guards have put the NBA
on complete notice and my my my
brother's GM so always tell me if you're
if you're going to bet on something you
should bet on a Kentucky guard can't go
wrong what can you say about that
development I mean you guys seem like
you guys have great development going
into college but then you explode when
you get to the NBA honestly I just think
Coach Cal does a really good job of
pushing us um I was telling somebody the
other day for me uh he just did a really
good job of making basketball different
for me uh I think basketball growing up
I was blessed to have a lot of
opportunities and a lot of love and a
lot of different things where I work my
way up to the top and basketball came
easy to me uh when I got to college he
was able to challenge me he did
different things in practice where he
challenged me then in the game he
challenged me to be better and I think
that is why guys like myself guys like
Jamal guys like de guys like sh I mean I
can go to you know the list goes on and
on uh when they get to the league they
sucel because one he pushed you in
practice and then you have somebody else
there pushing you shout out to Quick he
was the one pushing me so it's like you
see us when we get out here we're not
afraid of anything and we know know
we're going to try to go take the moment
I'm mad I just helped Cal
recruit your game winner you got to take
a shot on the court where's your game
winner you're I get a shot you get a
shot forend a real shot a real shot Ain
no pressure no
pressure I'm going go I'm going go I'm
going shoot a three you going to shoot a
three I'm going shoot a three okay
College three oh you're getting back
there okay okay there's two step oh
that's all right that's all right
he we still believe in you break he got
fou he got
fou for tomorrow I can't afford to break
nothing right now I can't afford to
break nothing right now all right we
appreciate you my friend no I appreciate
Allstar Tyrese Max that's what we're
saying putting it on
it